andrew and upon these institutions we
come together to simply celebrate
to thank you for being here
to say to president biden and madam vice
president that we are with you
in your efforts to stop filibuster we
are with you
to hold up voting rights act for the
united states of america
and make no mistake about it
this is not a black nor white issue
this is about democracy
so today mr president
madam vice president
we stand with you
as we choose democracy over autocracy
light overshadow and justice over
injustice because we are
the atlanta university consortium
that's who we are and we welcome you
to sacred ground
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
better
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
ah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
but
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ha ha ha ha ha foreign ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha
ha ha ha ha ha
[Music]
m
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
president of student government
association at spelman college jillian
jackson
ah
good afternoon everyone
my name is jillian jackson i'm a
graduating senior political science
major spanish minor from memphis
tennessee and i humbly serve as the 80th
spelman college sga president
thank you president biden vice president
harris and the white house personnel who
granted me the opportunity to speak with
you today
as we stand on these hallowed grounds of
our beloved atlanta university center we
stand on the shoulders of activists such
as julian vaughn
benjamin brown ruby doris smith and more
recently reverend rafael warnock and
stacey abrams
[Music]
it is our duty as campus leaders and
change agents to combat voter
discrimination on behalf of our peers
and surrounding west end community
we all are aware of georgia's current
legislation and how it poses a threat to
the voting rights of citizens
i distinctly remember registering to
vote at the naacp drive after turning 18
during my first semester at spelman
i was so eager to vote in my very first
election especially a gubernatorial one
unfortunately when attempting to vote
citizens face several challenges
including strict absentee requirements
limited polling place access and overall
lack of voter education
people wait hours in line to cast out
their civic duty to sometimes find that
they are unable to place their vote
because of tech technicalities
small mishaps like misspelled names
incorrect addresses as well as laws
preventing food and water distribution
to long polling place lines inhibit many
citizens and their right to vote
especially within the black community
i am so excited to hear the current
administration's plans to combat the
ongoing voting rights issues in our
state
without further delay it is my distinct
honor and pleasure to introduce the 46th
president of the united states of
america joe
biden and my fellow hbcu sister and
sorority sister vice president kamala
harris
[Music]
good afternoon atlanta
good afternoon
jillian thank you for that beautiful
introduction and for your leadership i
can't wait to see you what you do next
thank you
so last week
one year
yes please do sit
last week one year after a violent mob
reached the united states capital
the president of the united states and i
spoke from its hallowed halls
and we made clear
we swore
to preserve
protect
and defend
the constitution of the united states
and we will
we will fight
[Applause]
we will fight to safeguard
our democracy
we will fight
to secure
our most fundamental freedom
the freedom to vote
and that is why we have come to atlanta
today
to the cradle of the civil rights
movement
to the district that was represented by
the great congressman john lewis
[Music]
[Applause]
on the eve of the birthday
of reverend dr martin luther king jr
more than 55 years ago
men women and children
marched from selma to montgomery to
demand the ballot
and when they arrived at the state
capitol in alabama
dr king decried
what he called
normalcy
the normalcy
the complacency
that was denying people the freedom to
vote
the only normalcy anyone should accept
dr king said
is the normalcy of justice
and his words resonate today
over the past few years we have seen so
many anti-voter laws that there is a
danger
of becoming accustomed
to these laws
a danger
of adjusting to these laws as though
they are normal
a danger
of being complacent
complicit
anti-voter laws are not new in our
nation
but we must not be deceived into
thinking they are normal
we must not be deceived
into thinking
a law that makes it more difficult
for students to vote is normal
we must not be deceived
into thinking a law that makes it
illegal to help a voter with a
disability vote by mail
is normal
there is nothing normal
about a law that makes it illegal to
pass out water
or food to people standing in long
voting lines
and i have met with voters in georgia
i have heard your outrage about the
anti-voter law here
and how many voters will likely be kept
from voting
and georgia is not alone
across our nation anti-voter laws could
make it more difficult for as many as 55
million americans to vote
that is one out of six people in our
country
and the proponents of these laws are not
only putting in place
obstacles to the ballot box
they are also working to interfere with
our elections to get the outcomes they
want and to discredit those that they
don't
that is not how a democracy should work
my fellow americans
do not succumb
to those who would dismiss
this assault on voting rights
as an unfounded threat
who would wave this off as a partisan
game
the assault on our freedom to vote
will be felt by every american in every
community in every political party
and if we
stand idly by
our entire nation
will pay the price
for generations to come
as dr king said
the battle is in our hands
and today
the battle is in the hands
of the leaders
of
the american people
those in particular
that the american people sent
to the united states senate
two landmark bills
sit before the united states senate the
john lewis voting rights advancement act
and the freedom to vote act
[Applause]
and these two bills represent the first
real opportunity to secure the freedom
to vote
since the united states supreme court
gutted the voting rights act nearly a
decade ago
we do not know
when we will have this opportunity again
senate republicans
have exploited
arcane rules to block these bills
and let us be clear
the constitution of the united states
gives the congress the power to pass
legislation
and nowhere
nowhere
does the constitution give a minority
the right to unilaterally block
legislation
the american people have waited long
enough
the senate must act
and the bottom line is this
years from now our children and our
grandchildren
they will ask us about this moment
they will look back on this time
and they will ask us not about how we
felt
they will ask us
what did we do
we cannot tell them
that we let a senate rule
stand in the way
of our most fundamental freedom
instead
let us tell them
that we stood together
as people
of conscience
and courage
let us tell them
we acted
with the urgency that this moment
demands
and let us tell them we secured
the freedom to vote
that we insured
free and fair elections
and we safeguarded our democracy for
them
and their children
and now my fellow americans it is my
honor to introduce a leader who is
unwavering in his commitment
to defend our democracy
and ensure the ballot prevails
the president of the united states of
america joe biden
[Applause]
in our lives
[Music]
in the lives
of our nation life of our nation
there are moments so stark
that they divide
all that came before
and everything followed
they stop time
they rip away
the trivial
from the essential
and they force us to confront hard
truths
about ourselves
about our institutions and about our
democracy
and the words of scripture
remind us to hate evil
love good
and establish justice in the gate
last week
president harris and i
stood in the united states capital
to observe
one of those before
and after moments in american history
january 6th insurrection
on the citadel of our democracy
today
we come to atlanta
the cradle of civil rights
to make clear
what must come after
that dreadful day
when a dagger
was literally held at the throat
of american democracy
we stand on the grounds
to connect clark atlanta
atlanta university
morehouse college
near spelman college the home of
generations of advocates
activists educators and preachers
young people
just like the students here
who have done so much
to build a better america
[Applause]
we visited the sacred ebenezer bastard
church and paused to pray
that the crypt of dr and mrs king
and spent time with their family
and here in the district as was pointed
out represented
and reflected
the life of beloved friend john lewis
in their
lifetimes time
stopped
when obama blew up the 16th street
baptist church in birmingham
and murdered four little girls
they stopped
when john
and many other seeking justice
were beaten and bloodied
while crossing the bridge at selma
named after the grand dragon
of the ku klux klan
they stopped
time stopped
they forced the country to confront the
hard truths
and to act
to act to keep the promise of america
alive
the promise
that holds that we're all created equal
but more importantly deserve to be
treated equally
and from those moments of darkness and
despair
came light and hope
democrats and publics and independents
work to pass the historic civil rights
act and the voting rights legislation
and each successive generation
continued
that ongoing work
but then
the violent mob of january 6 2021
empowered and encouraged by a defeated
former president
sought to win through violence
what he had lost at the ballot box
to impose the will of the mob
to overturn
the free and fair election
and for the first time the first time
in american history
they to stop
the peaceful transfer of power
they failed
they failed
but democracies
but democracy's vision victory was not
certain
nor is democracy's future
that's why we're here today to stand
against the forces in america that value
power over principle
forces that attempted a coup
a coup against the legally expressed
will of the american people by sowing
doubt
inventing charges of fraud
and seeking to steal the 2020 election
from the people
they want chaos to reign
we want the people to rule
let me be clear this is not about me or
vice president harris or our party it's
about all of us
it's about the people it's about america
hear me plainly
the battle for the soul of america is
not over we must stand strong and stand
together to make sure january 6 marks
not the end democracy but the beginning
a renaissance of our democracy
you know
for the right to vote
and to have that vote counted
is democracy's threshold liberty
without it
nothing is possible
but with it anything is possible
while the denial of fair and free
elections is undemocratic it is not
unprecedented
black americans were denied full
citizenship voting rights until 1965.
women were denied the right to vote
just 100 years ago
the united states supreme court
in recent years has weakened the voting
rights act
and now
the defeated former president and his
supporters
used a big lie about the 2020 election
to fuel torrent
and torment and anti-voting laws
new laws
designed to suppress your vote to
subvert our elections
here in georgia
for years you've done the hard work of
democracy
registering voters
educating voters getting voters in the
polls
you build a broad coalition of voters
black white latino asian american
urban suburban rural
working class and middle class and it's
worked
you've changed the state
by bringing more people legally to the
polls
that's how you won the historic election
for senator raphael warnock and senator
john ossoff
you did it
you did it the right way the democratic
way
and what's been the reaction of
republicans in georgia
choose the wrong way
the undemocratic way
to them
too many people voting in a democracy is
a problem
so they're putting up obstacles
for example
voting by mail is a safe and convenient
way to get more people to vote
so they're making it harder
for you to vote by mail
the same way i might add in the 2020
election
president trump voted from behind the
desk in the white house in florida
dropping your ballots off to secure
drop boxes
it's safe
it's convenient
and you get more people to vote
so they're limiting the number of drop
boxes and the hours you can use them
taking away the options
has a predictable effect
longer lines at the poles
lines that can last for hours
you've seen it with your own eyes
people get tired they get hungry
when the bible teaches us to feed the
hungry and give water to the thirsty
the new georgia law actually makes it
illegal
think of this i mean
2020
and now 22 going into that election it
makes it illegal
to bring your neighbors
your fellow voters food or water
while they wait in line to vote
what in the hell heck are we talking
about
i mean think about it
[Music]
that's not america
that's what it looks like
when they suppress the right to vote
and here's how they plan to subvert the
election
the georgia republican party the state
legislature
has now given itself the power
to make it easier for partisan actors
their cronies
to remove local election officials
think about that
what happened the last election
the former president and allies pursued
threatened and
intimidated state and local election
officials
election workers ordinary citizens
were subject to death threats
many seen phone calls
people stalking them in their homes
remember what the defeated former
president said to the highest ranking
election official a republican in this
state
he said quote
i just want to find 11
780 votes
pray god
he didn't say that part
he didn't say count the votes
he said find votes
that he needed to win
he failed because of the courageous
officials democrats republicans
who did their duty and upheld the law
but with this new law in georgia
his loyal his loyalists will be placed
in charge of state elections
what is that going to mean
well the chances
for chaos and subversion are even
greater as partisans seek the results
they want no matter what the voters have
said no matter what the count
the votes of nearly 5 million georgians
will be up for grabs if that law holds
it's not just here in georgia
last year alone 19 states
not proposed but enacted 34 laws
attacking voting rights
there were nearly 400 additional bills
republican members of state legislatures
tried to pass
and now
republican legislators in several states
have already announced plans to escalate
the onslaught this year
their end game
to turn the will of the voters into a
mere suggestion
something states
can respect or ignore
jim crow 2.0 is about two insidious
things
voter suppression and election
subversion
it's no longer about who gets to vote
it's about making it harder to vote
it's about who gets to count the vote
and whether your vote counts at all it's
not hyperbole this is a fact
look this matters to all of us
the goal the former president as allies
is to disenfranchise anyone who votes
against them simple as that
the facts won't matter
your vote won't matter
they'll just decide what they want
and then do it
that's the kind of power you see in
totalitarian states not in democracies
we must be vigilant
and the world is watching
i know the majority of the world leaders
the good and the bad ones
adversaries and allies alike
they're watching american democracy and
seeing whether we can meet this moment
and that's not hyperbole
when i showed up at the g7 with seven
other world leaders there were total
nine present
vice president harris and i have spent
our careers
doing this work i said america's back
and the response was
for how long
for how long
as someone who's worked in foreign
policy my whole life i never thought i
would ever hear
our allies
say something like that
over the past year
we've directed federal agencies to
promote access to voting
led by the vice president we've
appointed
top civil rights advocates to help the
u.s department of justice
which has doubled its voting rights
enforcement staff
and today
we call on congress to get done what
history will judge
pass the freedom to vote act
pass it now
but to prevent voter suppression
so here in georgia
there's full access to voting by mail
there are enough drop boxes during the
enough hours so they can bring food and
water as well
to people waiting in line
the freedom of the vote act
takes on election subversion
to protect nonpartisan electors
officials
who doing their job from intimidation
and interference
would get dark money out of politics
create fair district maps and ending
partisan gerrymandering
look
it's also time to pass the john lewis
voting rights advancement act
i've been having these quiet
conversations with members of congress
for the last two months i'm tired of
being quiet
folks
it'll restore the strength of the voting
rights act of 65.
the one president johnson signed after
john lewis was beaten nearly killed on
bloody sunday
only to have the supreme court weakened
in multiple times over the past decade
the voting rights act would mean the
justice department can stop
discriminatory laws before they go into
effect
before they go into effect
the vice president and i
have supported voting rights bills since
day one of this administration but each
and every time
senate republicans have blocked the way
republicans oppose even debating the
issue hear me
i've been around the senate a long time
i was vice president for eight years
i've never seen a circumstance we're not
one
single republican
has a voice
that's ready to speak for justice now
when i was a senator including
when i headed up the judiciary committee
i helped reauthorize the voting act
three times
we held hearings we debated we voted
i was able to extend the voting rights
act for 25 years
in 2006 the voting right act passed 390
to 33 in the house of representatives
and 98-0 in the senate
with votes from 16
current
sitting republicans in this united
states senate 16 of them
voted to extend it
the last year hours chairman
some of my friends sitting down here
will tell you
strom thurman
voted to extend the voting rights act
it's trump thurman
you can say that again wow
you have no idea how damn darn hard i
worked on that one
but folks
then it was signed the law
the last time
by president george w bush
you know
when we get voting rights extended
in 1980 as i said even thurman supported
it think about that
the man who led the longest full about
one of the longest filibusters in
history in the united states senate 1957
against the voting rights act the man
who led
and sided with all southern bulls in the
united states senate to perpetuate
segregation in this nation even tom
thurman
came to support voting rights but
republicans in the day can't and won't
not a single republican
has displayed the courage to stand up
to a defeated president
to protect america's right to vote not
one
not one
we have 50 50 in the united states
senate that means we have 51 presidents
you all think i'm kidding
i've been pretty good at working with
senators my career
but man when you've got 51 presidents
it gets harder anyone can change
the outcome
sadly
the united states senate
designed to be the world's greatest
deliberative body
has been rendered a shell of its former
self
gives me no satisfaction in saying that
as an institutionalist as a man
was honored to serve in the senate
but as an institutionalist
i believe the threat to our democracy is
so grave
that we must find a way to pass these
voting rights bill debate them vote let
the majority prevail
and if that bare minimum is blocked
we have no option but to change the
senate rules including getting rid of
the filibuster for this
you know
last year if i'm not mistaken the
filibuster was used 154
times
the filibuster has been used to generate
compromise in the past
promote some bipartisan but is also
used to obstruct
including especially obstruct civil
rights and voting rights
and when it was used centers
traditionally used to have to stand and
speak
at their desk for however long it took
and sometimes it took hours
and when they sat down if no one
immediately stood up
anyone could call for a vote
or the debate ended
but that doesn't happen today senators
no longer even have to speak one word
filibuster is not used by republicans
to bring the senate together but to pull
it further apart
filibusters have weaponized and abused
all the state legislative assaults on
voting rights majority
the united states senate it takes a
super majority 60 votes
even to get a vote instead of 50 to
protect the right to vote
state legislators can pass anti-voting
laws
simple majorities
if they can do that then the united
states senate should be able to check
voting rights by a simple majority
today
i'm making it clear to protect our
democracy
i support changing the senate rules
whichever way they need to be changed to
prevent
a minority of senators from blocking
action on voting rights
when it comes to protecting majority
rule
in america the majority should rule in
the united states senate
i make this announcement with careful
deliberation recognizing the fundamental
right to vote is a right from which all
other rights flow
and i make it with an appeal to my
republican colleagues
to those republicans who believe in the
rule of law
restore
the bipartisan tradition of voting
rights
people who restored it who abided by in
the past were richard nixon
gerald ford
ronald reagan
george h.w bush
george w bush
they all
supported the voting rights act
don't let the republican party morph
into something else
restore the institution of the senate
the way it was designed to be
senate rules
were just changed to raise the debt
ceiling so we wouldn't renege on our
debt for the first time in our history
to prevent an economic crisis
that was done
by a simple majority
as senator warnock said a few weeks ago
in a powerful speech
if we change the rules to protect the
full faith and credit of the united
states we should be able to change the
rules to protect the heart and soul of
our democracy
he was right
the days that followed john lewis's
death there was an outpouring of praise
and support across the political
spectrum
but as we stand here today
isn't enough just to praise his memory
we must translate eulogy into action
we need to follow john lewis's footsteps
we need to support the bill in his name
just a few days ago
we talked about
up in the congress and the white house
the
event coming up shortly to celebrate dr
king's birthday
and americans of all stripes
will praise him for the content of his
character
but as dr king's family said before
it's not enough to praise their father
they even said
on this holiday don't celebrate his
birthday unless you're willing to
support what he lived for and what he
died for
the next few days
when these bills come to a vote
will mark a turning point in this
nation's history
we will choose
the issue is will we choose
democracy over autocracy
light over shadows
justice over injustice
i know where i stand
i will not yield i will not flinch i
will defend the right to vote our
democracy against all enemies foreign
and yes domestic
the question is
where will the institution of the united
states senate stand
every senator democrat republican and
independent want to declare where they
stand
not just for the moment
but for the ages
will you stand against voter suppression
yes or no that's the question they'll
answer
will you stand against election
subversion
yes or no
will you stand for democracy
yes or no
there's one thing every senator and
every american should remember
history has never been kind to those
who've sided with voter suppression over
voters rights
and let me even be less kind
for those who side with election
subversion
so i ask every elected official in
america
how do you want to be remembered
the consequential moments in history
they present a choice
do you want to be the sign the side of
dr king
or george wallace
do you want to be in the side of john
lewis
or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
this is the moment to decide
to defend our elections to defend our
democracy
and if you do that you will not be alone
that's because the struggle to protect
voting rights has never been borne
by one group alone
we saw freedom riders of every race
leaders of every faith marching arm and
arm
and yes democrats and republicans in
congress of the united states
and in the presidency
i did not live the struggles of douglas
tubman king louis goodman cheney swerner
countless others known and unknown
i did not walk in the shoes of
generations of students who walked these
grounds
but i walked other grounds because i'm
so damn old i was there as well
they think i'm kidding man
seems like yesterday the first time i
got arrested anyway
but their struggles
here
they're the ones that opened my eyes
as a high school student
in the late in the late 50s and early
60s
they got me more engaged in the work of
my life
and what we're talking about today is
rooted in the very idea of america
the idea
that anil ponder who graduated from
clark atlanta
captured in a single word
she was a teacher and a librarian
who was also an unyielding champion
of voting rights
in 1963
i was just starting college university
after registering voters in mississippi
she was pulled off a bus
arrested and jailed
where she was brutally beaten
in her cell next to her
was fannie lou
hamer who described the beating this way
and i quote
i could hear the sounds of the licks
and the horrible screams
they beat her
i don't know for how long
and after a while she began to pray
and ask god to have mercy
on those people
and they'll ponder friends
visit her the next day
her face was badly swollen
she could hardly talk
but she managed to win mr whisper one
word
freedom
freedom
the only word she whispered
after nearly 250 years since our
founding
that singular idea still echoes but it's
up to all of us
to make sure it never fades
especially the students here
your generation
that just started voting
as there are those who are trying to
take away that bite vote you just
started to be able to exercise
but the giants we honor today were your
age
when they made clear
who
we must be as a nation
not a joke think about it
in the early 60s
they were sitting where you're sitting
they were you
and like them
you give me much hope for the future
before and after
in our lives and the life of this nation
democracy is who we are
who we must be
now and forever so let's stand in this
breach together
let's love good
establish justice in the gate and
remember as i said
there is one this is one of those
defining moments in american history
each of those who vote will be
remembered
by class after class in the 50s and 60s
the 2000s and 50s and 60s
each one of the members of the senate
is going to be judged by history
on where they stood before the vote
and where they stood after the vote
there's no escape
so let's get back to work
as my father my grandfather finney used
to say every time i walk out the door
and scranton he said joey keep the faith
then he'd say no joey spread it
let's spread the faith and get this done
may god bless you all and may god
protect the sacred right to vote
thank you i mean it let's go get this
done
thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you